he's not why wondrin god Oh who's yours
des hey youtubers it's Charlie happy
Halloween since we all love Game of
Thrones so much and we all love
Halloween so much I thought it'd be
awesome to put the two together like
Game of Thrones is the peanut butter and
Halloween is the chocolate I guess that
would make my channel like the Reese's
Pieces of YouTube so let me start by
saying officially there's no actual
halloween that they celebrate in Game of
Thrones or in the world of Westeros or
asos but they do pray to the stranger
it's a lot like the Day of the Dead or
honoring the dead which is actually a
separate holiday in real life Dia de los
Muertos but they do actually have
something that they do to honor the dead
or pray to the god of death so here's
what I'm going to do in honor of
Halloween I'm going to talk about my
favorite moments on the show and in the
series that invoke the stranger and then
I'm going to talk about my favorite
scariest moments on the show just in
case this first part includes a few
spoilers that you haven't heard about
yet consider this your mild spoiler
warning for books four and five right
away there are two characters in Game of
Thrones that really invoke the stranger
or evoke themes of the stranger and that
is one aria very obviously and to Cersei
the aria is so deep in bodies in a game
of thrones that she's like the physical
avatar of death on the show like if this
were avatar the last airbender series
she would be a death bender she's very
devout she actually praised to the
stranger that prayer she says actually
goes wiese Dunson chiswick polliver raff
the sweetling the tickler the house or
Gregor sir armory sir Ilyn ser Meryn
King Joffrey and Queen Cersei and then
it ends with ferg our vocalist he even
tells barrack in the cave of the
brotherhood that she worships death I'm
actually hoping at a certain point that
the show takes her to the east so we can
meet the Faceless Men they're basically
like an order of assassins that could be
considered like priests of the faceless
one pathology gets a little metal but
the faceless one is a lot like the
stranger they're almost the same God
although some people would argue that
they're separate God's but they're
basically like many aspect gods that
represent death and the unknown Cersei
is associated with a stranger in a
slightly different way she doesn't wade
through bodies like aria does he
represents mostly the unknown aspect of
the stranger which basically means she
hides her true self Amy actually calls
us out in before and it's mostly because
Cersei lies so much so essentially she
hides her true purpose Jamie actually
has this really nice moment in the
series
where he basically called Cersei out
internally at least for Oliver [ __ ]
so if Cersei is the physical embodiment
of anything on the show its deception so
she actually has a lot of POV chapters
in book four so if you haven't read that
yet you are in for a treat but what
about my favorite scary moments on the
show and full disclosure I have read the
book so when I saw the scary moments on
the show or the really shocking moments
I view them in a slightly different way
than people who were seeing them for the
first time or didn't know they were
coming but here they are in order from
really scary too I just threw up in
front of my TV number three that moment
at the end of season two with a white
Walker army marches past Samwell this is
like the beginning of a full-scale
zombie invasion they just walked right
out of the Miss and it's really
terrifying they creep a lot like walkers
on the walking dead I use the walking
dead Association just because we don't
know how fast the whites can move we've
seen white walkers use weapons really
quickly so we know they can move really
fast they're more like the George a
Romero zombies that kind of evolved over
time and gain certain intelligence but
that white Walker moment is more
terrifying that it is truly horrifying
the differences is that a terrifying
moment is like when a bear is chasing
you through the woods it doesn't really
affect your sense of self you're just
really scared you're like I don't want
this thing to catch me and kill me
horrifying is something that just alters
your fundamental sense of self which
leads me to number two number two Jamie
getting his hand cut off this moment was
actually still so shocking to watch on
screen that I was still a little scared
a week after I saw it I almost threw up
on my mouth a little bit when I saw it
on the show so the idea now is that
Jamie's fundamental sense of self has
completely changed like after the
physical trauma were off the
psychological damage start to set in so
he basically had to relearn how to
become a person but the good thing is is
there's a lot of hope because the person
he's turning into is actually much more
positive person than the person he was
before he lost his hand but this
actually leads me to my favorite
scariest moment on the show a moment
from which this character will never
recover psychologically or physically
number one my favorite scariest moment
on the show beyond becoming reek
obviously fee on becoming reek is a long
torturous process and people get
tortured on the show all the time but
how often do you have to watch someone
get there you know what cut off so going
forward now nothing that fee on ever
does or ever experiences will repair the
psychological or physical damage done to
him by Ramsay snow even if he ever gets
his revenge moment
it still won't heal the damage he is
reek now and forever for all time and
that is horrifying but now it's your
turn to tell me your favorite scariest
moments on the show they can be
something that I just mentioned or they
can be something that you thought was
going to happen on the show but didn't
end up happening let me know since it's
Halloween and Dracula just aired I feel
like it would be silly for me not to do
review that show even if i'm not going
to do a review every week be sure to
subscribe to get that i'll be posting
that tonight i hope you guys all have a
wonderful halloween thank you so much
for helping me get to 30,000 subscribers
so fast i still might go is Jon Snow
I've been growing my hair out long
enough right now you can click here to
watch that Dracula video and you can
click here to watch all my other Game of
Thrones videos thank you so much for
watching happy Halloween high fives to
everyone see you guys tonight
you